ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show uh we are here and uh we
have been absent
from your computer screen for about 10
days and we apologize for that uh I was
in Ibiza
um All Summer in Ibiza and the Amalfi
Coast
and all of those places and I'm there
because I'm invited and that's why I go
because when you are doing whatever
you're doing I'm in Ibiza with my
friends and I'm in the Amalfi Coast and
the south of France and Denver where I
was actually I was actually in Denver I
was in Denver America's Ibiza Denver
uh Colorado doing stand-up comedy at the
one of the greatest clubs in the world
uh the Denver Comedy Works and we had
amazing shows even the Sunday show at 4
P.M
you forget how fun it is to do comedy
for 300 uh 380 people however however
big the room is
um but it was intimate it was fun and
thank you to everybody that came out the
American royalty tour is on sale right
now Tim dilloncomedy.com all of my dates
are up including
uh Carnegie Hall where I'm gonna take my
own life
um so that is you know whether you want
to buy a ticket to a show after that is
something but I am ceremoniously going
to take my own life at Carnegie Hall uh
after the show
um but
um I'm kidding uh of course the dates
are on the website we're not going to go
through all the dates you can read
um I like Denver it's a town uh stuck in
the 90s
um it is
oddly without an identity
um and I don't know it's not quite
Portland in Seattle it's for people that
like it a little weird but not as far
gone as Portland OR Seattle you want
your girlfriend to be bisexual not
non-binary if you're in Denver you can
have blue hair you can finger your
friend but you gotta be a gender it's
Denver and then if you go to Portland OR
Seattle then you can really let [__]
loose but that's what Denver seems to be
you know you see the people hiking it's
the outdoors the mountains they don't
know they're empty vessels in Denver
they're trying to get filled up with
something
and I'm bloated now because I was in
Denver the oxygen because it's high
altitude and don't say and I know what
all of you are going to say I know what
you're gonna say that's not what I know
what's gonna happen every comment top
comment bloated because he's in Denver
I know what you're gonna say it is a
fact that at high altitudes people bloat
that is a fact that I have read because
the air in your stomach
begins to you know and it just you go
out like that in Denver because I was up
at the altitude of around 5
000 something feet and that that is a
huge reason
uh for the bloating and I know that many
people will disagree with that or have
their own you know snide remark you can
have a snide remark about it but it's
the facts it's true but that's where I
was so that's uh I was not in a beef
um but to everyone who is that's great
I'm not mad at anybody everyone's on
vacation now everybody every comedian
every human being I know
is on vacation somewhere cool
and I am not
everybody I know is in Europe or Italy
or Croatia and I am in Denver eating a
green chili which is not good green
chili is not good I don't know what it
is
it is not good and I'm eating a green
chili burrito
the bloating is the altitude but I was
eating a green chili smothered burrito
uh in Denver
not in Ibiza
but in the mile high city
uh Denver
and in that time that I was away from
you all I imagine I've heard about and
this is not a big deal it's the summer
and the Obamas killed a sex slave and
it's such a
it's so strange to me that this even
makes news and that any of you are
shocked by this
there was a really hot Chef who worked
for the Obamas
he's a hot Chef which by the way
immediately again it's like okay even
though chefs are getting hotter
uh Safari Campbell R.I.P paddle boarding
death riddle
cops left call log reporting Obama's
private Chef drowning blank and said it
came from two miles away as they refused
to reveal who he was with on the water
if I was Obama
and I am and if I was gay which I am but
I'm not black and I wasn't the president
but if I was
bisexual Maybe
and I would have a hot chef
I would and I would [__] the hot chef
and if the hot chef and this is again
purely speculative I don't know anything
I'm just telling you what I would do
what I would do so don't say I'm
spreading a conspiracies or entertaining
I'm telling you personally what I would
do I would [__] the hot Chef if the hot
Chef got mouthy I would drown him in a
pond
that's what I would do and I don't know
if that's what Obama did I don't know if
that's what
um he had done I'm just telling you if
that was me it's very strange that
anyone drowns in a pond it can happen
sure it can happen
these things can happen
he was supposedly a very strong swimmer
I think the people were putting up
videos of him swimming
um
Martha's Vineyard police left the reason
for the 9-1-1 call reporting Obama
private Chef tafari Campbell's drowning
why would they leave it blank
the night of the accident
yeah there was just maybe they didn't
know there was just hours missing they
blacked like you can't request the
public records of it for some reason so
they just you're never going to hear
these 911 calls usually they play them
on the news the Democrats run Martha's
Vineyard yeah they've done it they've
ran it since Teddy Kennedy
and that [__] went in the water
they since they ran it they've run it
that's their uh that's their Island
the Republicans have Palm Beach
Jeffy Epps
just Lane Trump they have Palm Beach
Democrats have Martha's Vineyard The
Hamptons a little bit for everybody but
that is a Democrat Island and they take
care of their own they protect their own
if somebody's dead in a pond we don't
know why that happened
they go let's get to that
now this is sad
we don't know what happened clearly
um it's a
apparently he was at their residence
and they aren't there is that odd
do you let the chef use the residence
I'm asking I'm I'm asking that
even though he's a family friend does
the chef
get to use the estate in Martha's
Vineyard when you're not there
the [__] he does it my chef
my chef
what do you do who are you cooking eggs
for you're going to my estate which is
is this what we're being fed that's the
reality right no one's there right it's
the chef
the chef calls Obama
and goes I need some time to reflect
and and Obama goes why don't you stay at
our house
is this weird am I nuts
am I crazy I'm asking the quest like I
don't know I'm thinking of how this goes
down
do they offer him the property
does she say this Michelle go like
hey
if you ever want you know we got that
space out there we got that spot why
don't you enjoy it
is this what goes on does like Bill
Clinton's dog walker go to his house
when they're not there
who's going to what's happening
is the guy the chef or is he a family
friend I know he's a family do you have
videos of him swimming yeah yeah here we
go there's videos of this man swimming
supposedly he drowned and I thought he
was in the open ocean now by the way
guys don't come at me and say uh you're
a conspiracy monger
I'm not a conspiracy Monger I don't talk
about anything that's not proven I
respect Obama and I respect Big Mike and
I won't ever entertain spreading
narratives that aren't true if Big Mike
says this happened it happened and I
have no issue believing that let's see
if this guy can swim so this is him
swimming from seven years ago eight
years ago well what happened in those
seven or eight years he is he probably
got even better as a swimmer let's see
he's not great he's not using his arms
well he's he's kicking
okay here he goes he's got flippers on
though that's kind of cheating he's
doing fine
it's a pond
this man was murdered
so he became their chef
wow the Clinton's White House shaft now
this is interesting
this is fun summer stuff
is this true though Travis
uh there's several chefs that have uh
died did you know that the clintons
White House Chef also died from drowning
in 2015. I saw this thing how does this
have folks
does anybody is this
can you question anything
is everybody's Shaft or sit there estate
when they're not there
what I mean that's even more disturbing
to me than them being drowned here we go
New York get the help off the property
if they're not working
they listen if you are a chef and one of
these [__] goes use my house
they were trying to kill you they want
to kill you they don't want the chef in
their house unless you're cooking them
food
yeah they don't want you in their
[__] house
it's the first rule of being rich you
want to own a lot of houses and have
them be empty
tafari Campbell's drowning parallel's
tragic death of Clinton chef
what
that's right the tragic drowning death
of former White House sous chef and
Obama's personal chef tafari Campbell
over the weekend they're sadly similar
to the premature demise of another white
house kitchen veteran
Campbell's death comes just eight years
after Walter
sheep
who served as the White House executive
chef from 1994 to 2005 and was found
partially submerged in a ravine in the
New Mexico mountains
in 2015
is reported missing by his girlfriend on
June 14th one day after he failed to
return from a hike
well maybe that's
more
reasonable because he's hiking out in
nature
I don't know now this guy Campbell is on
a paddle board in a pond do you have any
photo of the pond behind the Martha's
Vineyard property
I'm never going to March's Vineyard
you're not going to kill me if I drown
they killed me I'm an incredibly strong
swimmer if I drown I was murdered by the
Obamas
because so this is the pond and what is
it called
it's pretty big
town I think it's Edgar Town Pond it's
pretty big they have a they have a
stunning estate on Martha's Vineyard
which is a beautiful Island
off the coast of Massachusetts where
wealthy celebrities and politicians a
lot of political people have homes and
sadly this Obama chef
was there alone he was alone
that's what they say he was alone in the
house well there was another person
paddle boarding with him but they won't
say who it was yet
okay
fair enough the former first couple of
purchased a nearly 7 000 square foot
home on Martha's Vineyard in
Massachusetts for 11.75 million
and that was in 2019. so somebody's
paddle boarding with this guy this guy
is a medical emergency which can happen
Strokes aneurysms aortic whatever
and he goes down
or
the person paddle boarding with him
he says something like you know this
thing with Barack I want to talk about
it
I feel like we had something
and then the person on the paddle board
is you can't do that
that's not the way the world works
and then he's like yeah but I just have
to
and they're like it's you know it's
isn't it
and then they they you know inject them
with something on the board because he's
paddling and they paddle up to him and
they get him I mean that's maybe I don't
know and then it appears maybe like a
heart attack or something
I don't know I I just know this is this
is very sad I hope it's natural causes I
don't really know I just find the entire
thing strange
to me
that doesn't mean that it's not
valid or you know that doesn't mean that
it obviously me it's very tragic and I'm
not trying to make light of the tragedy
of it
um
but if if if they killed him
for a good reason
then that's what it is
and that's you know that's that
you know that's a way to do it
somebody's that that's still weird [__]
happens around these people around these
people that run our country very strange
things tend to happen people are
suicidal people of all kinds of weird
accidents people get stuck in Ravines
people collapse on paddle boards
this happens a lot around the people
that run the country a lot of their
employees Secret Service agents people
that are tasked with spending the
day-to-day with them don't make it they
don't make it so I don't know what
they're watching I don't know what
they're walking in on during breakfast I
don't know what they're seeing I don't
know what conversations they're hearing
late at night but whatever it is God is
at a deadly job that is a hazardous
being around anyone who runs this
country is a hazardous job and and all
we talk about is PR and I'm not sucking
off Putin because he won't let me no I'm
kidding but I won't I'm not what I'm
saying is that all we talk about is that
he's poisoning that one and he's
poisoning that and he probably is I have
no doubt he he gets uh you know gets a
little acute with a couple of nerve
agents over there but
the people that run this country every I
mean everybody's dead dog walkers or any
spontaneously combusting into flames
everybody that's near any of these
people goes down in a pond or something
and again it could be an accident but
they're numbers they stack up they just
start stacking up
Antonin Scalia
uh gets
didn't he he got shot in the face by
Dick Cheney right
Scalia died on a hunting trip it was uh
right that's another fun one
right Anthony Scalia died on a in a
hunting trip right yeah but didn't he
get shot by accident
no not Scalia Cheney shot Scalia is
still alive no
scalia's dead how did Scalia die Scalia
died from like natural causes on a
hunting trip okay
but stage someone shot someone in the
face yes Cheney shot uh who was it
there's a lot of my point is there's
lots of accidents
Harry Harry Whittington that's who Dick
Cheney shot there's tons of accidents to
be around these just being around these
people is hazardous to your health
anywhere near any of them people end up
dying get shot in the face
they fall into a pond
and maybe it's all a coincidence and
maybe it's an accident but I'm just
saying maybe it's best to not
surround yourself with the in those
circles
it seems best
to not be
in the Obama estate when they're not
there what good will come of that I
wonder
what good will come of that
I was invited to stay at my boss's home
and he's not there
I wonder what will happen my boss who I
might have had a few interesting moments
with perhaps maybe don't drown me don't
even try to drown me because I will yell
if you try to drown me I will yell at
the beach and it'll be it'll be very
embarrassing for everyone and it will
scar the children watching it if people
try to drown you have to Old School
drown me like you have to like put me in
a dunk tank and
it'll be very crude
um
I'll move on from that I don't I don't
want to keep talking about this I feel
bad R.I.P to
this person I don't know there's no
information this is the other thing with
this nobody will ever know anything
about any of these things ever
and it will you'll just either way go
okay
I don't know you know it won't
it will matter or it won't I don't know
do you know who should have
um taken legal action against uh people
Princess Diana
35 percent of all fatal accidents occur
between 6 pm and midnight
[Laughter]
people aged 25 to 34 have the highest
amount of drivers involved in car
crashes people aged 15 to 24 the highest
amounts of emergency room visits due to
accidents of all age groups
submitting an injury claim with Morgan
and Morgan is easy
please use one oh sorry
it's more like using an app than hiring
a lawyer submitting a claim to mortgage
and mortgage is as easy as pie
submitting a claim to Morgan and Morgan
is as easy as pretending you didn't see
that 5 PM email they only collect if you
win that's really cool you know they're
not there to get all the money out of
you you know here look look at me look
at me
I'm driving in my car
okay next to my middle eastern uh
boyfriend fiance
here I go uh oh
I noticed something's wrong
people are on motorcycles are they
paparazzi
are they intelligence agents we don't
know are they intelligence agents with
cameras I don't know anyway I ignore
them I'm kind of used to Paparazzi then
all of a sudden
laughs
royal family wins again
and
had I survived I would have gone Morgan
Morgan if you're ever injured you can
check out Morgan and Morgan their fee is
free unless they went for more
information go to forthepeople.com Tim
or dial pound law pound 529 from your
cell phone that's for the people.com Tim
or pound law pound 529 from yourself
this is a paid
advertisement I'm the people's princess
[Laughter]
in the summer of fat
um they're filling a Reese's Peanut
Butter Cup like they're there should be
laws now with some of the restaurants
like there should actually be laws I'm
actually I believe a little bit like you
know Michael Bloomberg towards the end
of his run got very Nanny state
he started to behave like a petty
dictator he wanted to ban smoking and
ban large sodas and I think he didn't
really even love vehicles in the city
like he wanted just it to be simply
pedestrian like he had a lot of ideas
that were kind of infringing on people's
personal freedom but maybe this is why
people can have personal freedom let me
the Reese's Peanut Butter Cup is the
best candy in the world it has been for
years why why ratios
ratios it is a perfect ratio of
chocolate to peanut butter that's not a
novel concept I'm sure I've said it
millions of people have said it that's
what makes things good ratios sandwiches
what makes them good ratios how much
meat how much cheese how much bread how
much whatever
there is this peanut butter cup is
absolutely perfect as it is it should
only be altered maybe once a year during
Easter for that egg which isn't good
where they put it in the form of an egg
because of the holiday and because of
Christ but maybe that's the only time we
don't need to do like Oreo
I think kind of bombed when they tried
to go too crazy and we got to ban the
Franken food
like the Oreo cakester that's like it's
a cake it's not it's a cake that's
shaped like a cookie that you eat
you it can't happen now we have a
problem in this country like a very big
problem we have to ban Franken food
things that like the donut Burgers like
the things that aren't of nature not
that a peanut butter cup grows on a tree
but you know what I mean the things that
push it to the edge
where it's heinous where people look at
it and there's a Grimace on their face
because they can't even imagine eating
this crap we have to use the power of
the government now to stop this
stop the pop-ups in Times Square
you don't need like there was an m m
store now every candy
cereal there's a pop-up experience where
you can go in and and with your children
and and feed them garbage in like a fun
Disney ask environment
it we don't need it anymore and I I
think it's hurting people
so now here's the article that that made
me it's convert I'm fully converted to
this by the way I fully but you will not
find this in Europe
you will not go to France and and and
and have stuff your own one pound giant
Peanut Butter Cup
stuff your own one pound
happy summer by the way do you know
sweaty by the way in a majority of the
country right now you can't even walk
outside because it's so hot your tits
are sagging and there's a rash under
your tits right now most people not all
of them but a lot of them statistically
they're they have a tit rash
gender unimportant they have a a a a
rash and they are ignoring and they're I
guess smearing Eucerin on it so they can
go walk to get the big one pound Peanut
Butter Cup
show the video of this it's the most
disgusting thing I've ever seen
it is like to self-serve frozen yogurt
concept which I had a great bid on in my
first Comedy Central half hour that I
believe is available in Canada right now
because uh they did not show it anywhere
or Market it thanks Comedy Central
appreciate it now
um that being said
there is a uh the self-serve frozen
yogurt concept is you go in you choose
it's like Chipotle you know you choose
the mix-ins you choose the things you
eat this is failed miserably by the way
this idea that Americans should be able
to choose that's why the burritos at
Chipotle can't close that's why the
self-serve frozen yogurt costs 38
because Americans cannot handle the
freedom of choosing what goes in their
body it needs to be banned now Reese's
has something called stuff your cup
which is disgusting
families that go to this this should be
like to catch a predator they should go
right to jail a family that takes their
fat kids to stuff their Reese's cup
should go right to jail afterwards
because everybody's going to be a
legless Pig very soon
I'm telling you
I'm at least writing a novel
[__] on my parents for what they did
to me with food
save yourselves
resist off your cup let's let's watch a
little bit of this please Rocco World in
Hershey Pennsylvania you can make a
custom one pound Reese's Peanut Butter
Cup
[Music]
choose from a variety of your favorite
mixes so listen how sick this is by the
way so it said Hershey is it at is it
the theme park yeah
so it's what they call Hershey Park yeah
so at Hershey Park there's the peanut
butter cup experience or whatever stuff
your cup
it's a one pound chocolate cup
they put peanut butter in it this is
where it gets a little bit like Being
John Malkovich
they put crushed up peanut butter cups
in the cup
so you have a cup made of chocolate and
then peanut butter and then crushed the
peanut butter cups in
the cup with Reese's Pieces and other
things
I mean you you and they're eating this
it's 90 degrees it's 90 degrees and
they're eating it
it's 90 it's melting all over their
faces and they're eating it let's keep
watching
watches they're folded into fresh peanut
butter direct from the factory right
down the road
it's like Cold Stone but they do with
peanut butter
[Music]
your peanut butter is then transferred
into a cup made of real chocolate food
we add a few more toppings oh
and then the chocolate lid what is who's
this for it has been wrapped and ready
for you to take home to share or keep
all to yourself what
why would they even make that joke
you could take it home to share
or
I mean that that that's truly and I've
eaten some bad stuff and I know that
doesn't shock anyone that is bad
you cannot be taking your kids
you cannot be taking your kids to that
if you have any love
for them as parents
you have to tell them no
Mommy Daddy can we go to stuff your cup
no we can't
no we can't and you know why this is
what you tell them because the people
that are going to stuff your cup are
going to be dead
do you want to be dead do you want to be
dead soon
no okay well we're not going to stuff
your cup
because you're gonna drop dead tell them
use the word
you're gonna drop dead if we give you a
big cup of peanut butter with [__]
look at that potato chips and bacon I'm
looking at potato chips is that bacon
you can put potato chips and bacon bits
and fold them into peanut butter
I mean I I gotta be honest it's it's so
it doesn't even seem good
but that's where we're at now with food
it's like the new foods
are so over the top they know people are
going to get mad by the way where's the
outrage of this it said cancel them you
canceled Dylan Mulvaney and Bud Light
how about canceling these people they
want your kids eating bacon bits and
peanut butter and you're not gonna get
that's at least as bad as seeing Dylan
Mulvaney's the [__] uh face on a
bottle I can it's probably a hell of a
lot worse
they're normalizing just and by the way
you know kids imitate [__] so they're
just gonna be sitting at home with
peanut butter on the counter
smashing it with all kinds of crap in it
[__] I'm stuffing my cup
hey Mom and Dad to go what are you doing
I stuff like well we don't do that at
home we don't stuff our cup at home oh I
stuffed my cup wherever I walk I will
stuff my cup wherever I want
everybody that stays with me
uh in my house in New York goes these
beds are amazing what are they and they
go They're Helix literally I asked Helix
for mattresses and it gave me discounted
mattresses but I'd gladly pay more
because everybody loves these Helix
mattresses I've owned it mattresses it
cost thousands and thousands of dollars
you know all the other kinds of
tempur-pedics and all that stuff but
I'll tell you right now Helix is amazing
because you fill out a quiz and they're
like What's your deal are you a hot
sleeper cold sleeper you like you like
soft mattresses hard mattresses firm
mattresses are you somewhere in the
middle are you a side sleeper you sleep
on your stomach and what Helix is able
to do is they're able to basically
engineer the perfect mattress for you
um after this quiz it's so easy and I
mean I've had it for years everybody
really likes it that comes we have them
in every guest room
um and everyone is unique and sleeps
differently and they all like these
Helix mattresses right
um
so just you know if your spawn needs
some extra TLC they got you every Helix
mattress has a hybrid design combining
individually wrapped steel coils in the
base with premium foam layers on top
it's a perfect combination of comfort
and support Helix is over 20 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners go to Helix sleep.comd and
use code Helix partner 20. okay this is
their best offer yet it won't last long
with Helix better sleep starts now
genuinely I'm telling you these are the
best mattresses I own and they're the
most affordable and they're offering 20
of all mattresses and two free pillows
for our listeners Helix sleep.com slash
Tim d t i m d use code Helix partner 20
h e l i x p a r t n e r
partner 20 Helix partner 20. this is the
best offer yet I'm telling you you will
not regret it Helix is the best thing
that I've ever bought of all the
packages that get dropped off at my door
hands down the best box I get to open
every month as my box of Awesome from
bespoke post my box have also been
filled with carefully chosen gear uh
from the best small Brands around the
world let's see what I got this month oh
my God cool an oxygen mask box of
awesome has you covered from camping
gear Essentials cookout must-haves
drinking game upgrades box of
Awesomeness collections for every part
of your life it's from small businesses
a lot of them in the USA each box is
valued around seventy dollars but you
only pay a fraction of that price plus
with each I mean this is perfect
somebody's going away to school
somebody's leaving they're going
somewhere else you get them a gift they
remember it every single month they
remember what a good generous person you
are so if you don't want to get it for
yourself it's the best gift ever because
it's like 12 gifts in one
with each box of awesome you're
supporting small businesses ninety
percent of everything that comes in your
box of Awesomeness from a small up and
coming brand like Nike
kidding it's free to sign it's a comedy
show it's free to sign up and you can
skip a month or cancel any time get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome.com and enter the
code Tim till on the checkout that box
of awesome.com for 20 off your first box
box of awesome.com code Tim Dillon to
stay on the theme of fat uh and uh
filling your cup and maybe this person
has filled their their cup has runeth
over
uh with allegations and this is sad
because this is lizzo who has made
herself the queen of the fat people
and
whenever you are the queen of any and no
one seems to know this or have learned
this
um nobody seems to get if you
give yourself a title or you accept the
title that is given to you
uh the next thing that will happen will
be some type of War because if you are a
king or a queen from the time you are
crowned people are only thinking about
how you are going to be deposed how
you're going to be uh knocked off the
throne and
lizzo has become the queen of certainly
fat women
and the queen of the body positivity
the queen of you can do it regardless of
size the queen of you look good no
matter what you're wearing the queen of
damn [__] you go girl you do you she's
the queen of that type of attitude
beautiful at any size big is beautiful
bigger is beautiful don't shame me don't
mock me don't marginalize me I am what I
am
and she's become the queen of that
and
she takes a lot of hatred
uh about her body from people that say
nasty things
um she also takes a lot of criticism
from people that think she promotes an
unhealthy
uh body image it would you know be if I
as a big person
were uh crusading for everyone to be
like me
um
um and in my attitude with fat people is
I respect them I don't sleep with them
I'm too rich and I don't have very many
of them as friends
um they have to be watched very closely
I have many fats that I employ uh
sloth-like people
um uh and uh sometimes unmotivated
sometimes they have to be you have to
light a fire under their sizable ass to
get something going not always but I'm
just saying I've had mixed uh mixed
reviews with some of the fat people I've
hired
um and lizzo had this show which I make
fun of I make fun of it in my Act
I make fun of it uh it's called Uh watch
out for the big girls and this was a
show
where lizzo said I want to have fat
backup Dent see by the way
I wish I could sit down with her
because lizzo is now with this story
about to be a fan of the Tim Dylan show
I can always point
to I saw when David dobrik had that
issue he I said he's about to become a
fan of the Tim Dillon show you can
always pinpoint the moment in someone's
career when they become a fan of the Tim
Dillon show lizzo whether you know it or
not you are about to become a fan of the
Tim Dylan show because now you're gonna
start to hear things with uh virginiers
new new you're going to be it's virgin
ears because the you're gonna actually
hear me for the first time
after this event you're going to hear me
for the first time and you're going to
go you know some of what he's saying
makes sense
um number one what a mistake
to hire 10 lizos to to be if you look or
sound like me I am throwing you in front
of a train
there is zero
this idea that she's going to create a
community of fat lizos that are all
going to get along and love each other
that they're not going to turn around
and go why is this [__] the lead when
they all look like her
and they all are icing their [__]
ankle after the number and everybody is
going why is this [__] that so what
lizzo tried to do is she said we're
gonna have a show called watch out for
the big girls where I'm gonna get all
these fat backup dancers and I'm gonna
put them behind me and it's gonna be a
celebration of the body and of the big
girls dancing and everything like that
and and then so predictably like
everything they turned on her
they turned on lizzo number one they
turned on her because they said they
were weight shamed by lizzo
because there's a point when you're too
fat
and lizzo probably said listen we're all
fat we got to behave here because when
you have so many fat people
together
they can influence each other in
negative ways
and maybe lizzo walks in on two of these
dancers and they are eating a peanut
butter out of the jar together and and
pawing it out like the Poo would with
honey you know two of them are in the
room and lizard goes well oh hey guys we
got rehearsal right now
and these women are they just have their
fingers in the jar of peanut butter and
they're just licking it off and Liza
goes listen I'm a fat [__] I get it but
you have to be professionally fat
you know so this is the issue when you
have a bunch of fat people and bat is
all you everybody you know it's like a
bunch of junkies I've been in a house
with a bunch of junkies and then certain
people start deciding who's at like
being too much of a junkie
I used to hang out in crack houses where
certain people would like they'd be
sober for an hour and they would turn
around to somebody else and they'd go
you got to get your act together because
that's what junkies do in the same way
when you have a bunch of fat people and
somebody's been on keto for 13 minutes
they start looking at everybody else
going look at this fat pig look at that
piece of [__] huh there is a dysfunction
inherent in such a community where all
of these people are big
it's a thing you're not everybody's not
supposed to be fat
everybody's not supposed to be gay
everybody's not supposed to be anything
they're supposed to be you know you it's
like a little bit you give a couple of
fat people here a couple of gay people
here a couple of trans people here it
makes it interesting not ever not
everybody Oberlin College 70 of you
can't be gay non-binary LGBT whatever
that's not the thing
like it's a sprinkling you can't just
have every fat person in the world on a
tour bus can you imagine
lizzo's tour bus
pulling up in your town
and it's just one after the other it's
almost like these the eight Wonders of
the Seven Wonders of the World
when every single woman gets off that
tour bus each one fatter than the last
and they go that's the concert those are
the dancers
formalism dancers were weight shamed and
pressured while at a strip club here's
the other thing I want to say if you're
a fat person and you hire fat people one
of the fun things to do is to call them
fat
you can't call your thin employees fat
although that is fun too and uh you know
if you are thin it's mean to call fat
people fat but but it's kind of like the
n-word which I don't use because I'm not
black
but if I have a fat employee I should be
able to call them fat fatty boom Baddie
I should be able to call them piglet I
should be able to make jokes about their
weight because I am also fat and that
entitles me to make jokes about their
weight and demean them and if they can't
handle that they should not have taken
the job that is one of the benefits of a
fat person who hires fat people uh and
you you Curry favor with your thin
employees by brutalizing the fat ones in
front of the thin ones I will make fun
of my fat employee in in front of one of
my thin ones and the fat one you know
frumply goes away sad into the other
room and me and the thin one have that
moment of like look what we just did to
that fatty it's a bonding experience
okay
like we're not We're Not Gonna surf
together me in the thin one but we can
make fun of the the pig I've hired now
so lizzo
and by the way lizzo is smoking and
Joint right now in West Hollywood
listening to this going God I wish this
could make sense I wish this didn't make
sense
um three of lizzo's former dancers have
accused the singer of sexual harassment
and creating a hostile work environment
in a lawsuit filed Tuesday they also
allege that she pressured one of them to
touch a nude performer at an Amsterdam
Club they went to a strip club and
subjected the group to quote
excruciating audition uh and
excruciating audition after leveling
false accusations that they were
drinking on the job so they're basically
saying she's some type of emotional
terrorist going after everybody accusing
them of drinking haranguing them about
their weight and when they go to a strip
club I think I read the thing about the
Shrimp Club she was basically like touch
this naked uh male dancer and she like
got a chant going like do it do it do it
the person felt uncomfortable and then
they finally did it and uh you know it's
kind of like drunken Shenanigans at a
strip club I mean I know that you know
certain people will see that as
inappropriate to me
I don't know
um
you know I don't know how inappropriate
that is it's not like Liz was going
around
uh sexually harassing the dancers
um you know the suit filed in the Los
Angeles Superior Court and provided to
NBC News by the plaintiff's Law Firm
also accuses the captain of lizzo's
dance team of proselytizing to other
performers and deriding those who had
pre-marital sex while while sharing lewd
fantasies simulating oral sex and
publicly discussing the virginity of one
of the plaintiffs let me read that again
because there's a lot there
um it also accuses the captain of
lizzo's dance team of proselytizing to
other performers so I think she was a
Christian and she was telling people
that day she was kind of being
evangelizing and deriding those who had
premarital sex so she said you're a
[__] I'm a Christian but then she was
also at the same time sharing lewd
fantasies simulating oral sex and
publicly discussing the virginity of one
of the plaintiffs
um
so we got we got a whole host of uh
issues that
uh these dancers are upset about right
the hostile work environment uh saying
sexual harassment the suit brings claims
for religious and racial harassment
false imprisonment I mean what is that
interference with prospective economic
advantage and other allegations not
every claim is brought against each
defendant I mean listen people can bring
a lawsuit for anything and I'm sure
these lawyers think that they're going
to get a chunk of money or that lizzo is
going to settle this is meant I think to
tarnish Her Image and this will teach
someone a lesson and I think it should
teach lizzo a lesson
um when you elect to be the mayor
of the the fat people and the mayor of
the body positive and the mayor of you
got to remember this folks and I I don't
by the way I don't attack people
um
unless I feel
that a it's funny or B that they are
wrong if they're wrong I will say when
Meghan Markle and Prince Harry do
something I pounce because uh all of the
things that they do are so transparently
vulgar uh most of them are lies and the
ones that aren't lies are distorted uh
to a point where it becomes ridiculous
and all of those things come from a bad
place it's a place of wanting to be
famous wanting to have power over people
wanting to control people wanting to uh
you know force people to believe a
certain thing so that's why I pounded
them here's the thing with and this is
why I'm not attacking lizzo I don't know
and we've made fun of lizzo a bunch
lizzo forced answers to eat bananas
from sex workers vaginas during
Amsterdam well this is
[Laughter]
hold on I was just about to say I wasn't
really coming down here hard on lizzo
only because
what I'm saying is when you say hostile
work environment and all these things
right uh I need to know the specifics of
what's going on however this article
seems maybe to provide them lizzo forced
answers
three of lizzo's former dancers are
suing the good as hell performer as well
as big girl
big girl big touring big girl big
touring
and Charlene Quigley for allegedly
subjecting them to endure weight share
okay we know that
okay so apparently the Amsterdam thing
so apparently they were in Amsterdam and
earlier this year and then that's when
the banana incident happened but what is
the banana incident let's let's try to
find this here
uh because again I I have to judge these
claims based on their merits now the
headline is lizzo Forest uh
okay here we go
the lawsuit States things quickly got
out of hand at this Amsterdam strip club
lizzo began inviting cast members to
take turns touching the new performers
catching dildos launched from the
performers vaginas and eating bananas
protruding from the performer's vaginas
the suit also claims lizzo allegedly
pressured and goaded someone named Davis
I guess it's one of the dancers yeah I
read this into touching one nude
performer's breasts the plaintiff also
claims that just wants later lizzo 35
deceived them once again into attending
a nude show thereby quote robbing them
of the choice not to participate so what
you have there is lizzo likes to get
maybe some freaky stuff she likes to go
to the strip club she likes to get turnt
up she likes to get wild
she's got bananas it's always food isn't
it she has bananas uh flying out of the
[__] of these dancers and she's
making people eat it it is way over the
line for sure
um but you know did these girls in the
moment have a problem with this or was
this something that after the night out
because I could see this being
uncomfortable but they're all drunk and
lizzo's being like yeah
and then you know the rest of them are
you know everybody's drunk and
everybody's kind of had people kind of
like ooh gross but like nobody really
makes it clear how uncomfortable they
are
um and then they do this stuff and then
they do they decide afterwards like this
is this was way too far this was over
the line I don't know I think I think
lizzo's made a few big mistakes in her
career I think one of them is going
in the direction of virtue
uh and just saying like not just being
like hey I'm fat it is what it is
saying like I'm going I will be your
queen always a mistake
always a mistake
I will be your queen
and then inviting her fat subjects to
the strip club
and then they turn on her
because that never works when you go I'm
going to be your queen it never works
lizzo it doesn't work you you you now
have to understand that you're just a
singer who's fat
you're not it's not a revolutionary
thing
you know how many fat people have talked
into microphones a lot of them you know
how many fat people living famous many
many many
even fat black women have been [__]
famous heard of Oprah you're not the
first in line to the throne here you're
the first social media star
um who's actually a very good singer and
a really great musician
who felt all of this pressure coming at
you from these people to say well our
movement needs a queen be this queen
and you took on that mantle
and now you know people uh in your orbit
have turned on you and they want to take
you off that
throne and they want
you to come in now I don't know what
lizzo has lizzo issued a statement how
did she denied this I mean has the woman
because all we've heard is from her
uh you know big girls
this is by the way uh completely
predictable in every way
when you watch
the show the big girl show and you see
all of these people they all have trauma
right everybody has traumas everybody
goes
you know here's why I'm uh overweight or
here's why I'm big I I have trauma I was
never there so it was never that I was
never respected you know so a lot of
these traumas are going to come out is
her IG being lit up are people like
going crazy on her IG did she lock the
comments yeah she hasn't posted in a
while no but I mean what her most recent
thing usually when scandals happen like
the most recent thing
you know will be like it's very funny
sometimes I mean you'll see like the
most recent photo of somebody they're
like shirtless on a beach and they have
like a goofy caption and then like
literally the the next line will be
answer the allegations and it's just
like such a it's like such an
unfortunate final photo to have before
social media Hiatus answer the
allegation she was 16.
I don't know what lizzo does now
I don't know if she could does she fight
it
here's what she should do lizzo should
get super thin
it's now time to throw fat people under
the bus
put the ozempic in vain
get hot get thin declare war on fat
people write a book lizzo listen to me
yeah here they are in the comments so
you're out there fat shaming your
dancers the audacity
read the [__] room you got exposed so
they're coming at lizzo listen to me
listen to the Timberland show I'm gonna
tell you how to be okay
I'm going to tell you listen to me I
want you to look at me I know you're
watching I know people that know you
listen to me
the time for fat is over now you've made
enough money off the pigs
it's time to leave the barn God I could
I could do these I could never stop with
these I could do these for hours it's
time to leave the barn okay
here's what you have to do
you have to get hot you have to write a
book about Wellness
you have to go you have to denounce the
fats
you have to say it was all wrong you
were wrong you weren't thinking you were
in a haze of Insomnia Cookies Postmates
you have to
you know you have to it's you you need
to be on The Joe Rogan Experience my
good friend Joe Rogan you go on there
and you say Joe I am thin now a thin
lizzo on The Joe Rogan Experience is the
future of her career
you need to change turn from this fat
mainstream and become hot
turn around and say I was wrong I
shouldn't have I shouldn't have done
that I didn't I didn't mean to I was
acting out I knew it wasn't right at
night me and all the other dancers would
just stuff our faces with food
our joints were are were weary we were
icing all of our joints after the dance
you know we were just bloated at high
altitude in Denver trying to do a show
at the Colorado Springs Air Force
Academy
farting and [__] all over the place
it was wrong and I'm sorry but now I'm
hot
and I disowned the fat people
they are I am no longer the queen of fat
people lizzo look at me and watch me
don't make the mistake
don't get fatter God forbid
get thinner now
hot lizzo
salad lizzo
lizzo comes out with keto's salad
dressing yes or yes
there are so many economic opportunities
I should charge for this advice there
are so many economic opportunities right
now you've milked
them enough the fats
you've squeezed on the Rudders
you've milked them enough it's time to
get the healthy P the rogany crowd the
the wellness people the people that do
yoga that you know are reading about
water filtration systems the people that
are what non-GMO like lizzo and you
could like her song is good as hell like
imagine a lizzo song from a thin lizard
where she's like I used to be a pig
I was a big fat pig
but then I realized I was gross I was
disgusting
but now I'm hot and hotness is real and
it would be huge it would be huge my
legs used to chafe
rashes on my back and onto my titties
cause of the Sun but now I'm thin my
vagina smells much better now
I'm hot lizzo is hard and I'm gonna go
to heaven oh I'm gonna go to heaven with
my new thin [__] girls if you got a
thin [__] put your hands in the air
I I mean
that was freestyling free bowling it but
maybe that is good but that is the
advice for her you cannot double down
you can no longer be the queen of uh the
Hodge and the heifers it is time to move
on that is your free advice
heat it
or perish
I want to also talk about the Gilgo
Beach uh thing because I have not you
know uh covered this at all because I've
been
methodically taking it in I've been
reading I've been thinking I've been
talking to friends I have a friend that
lives in the area he tried he walks his
dog around there of course they have
this very elaborate you know they've
closed the street down and everything
else and you know it's a big crime scene
and uh the wife of Gilgo murder suspect
Rex huermann
uh files for divorce as woman shares
Eerie encounter with him
I don't know if I love the wife filing
for divorce here I don't think that that
maybe is called for
um
I do think it's funny that he I mean
what a boomer he's out he goes on this
creepy date
and the woman that he went on the date
with was like he was so excited to talk
about the
Gilgo Beach murders and he sat right up
and he knew all these weird details and
she's very uncomfortable with it
um and you know so this guy
he you know he would go around bars and
he would and he would just talk about
the Gilgo Beach murders and he'd go on
date like so
this is interesting because this is
um
kind of a commentary a little bit on the
suburbs
and
the hidden life
and the secret life and this to Dr
Jekyll Mr Hyde
component you have this guy he's an
architect
the thing about him which is interesting
is he's a very mediocre guy he's not
really rich he's not incredibly
successful
um yet he is also not broke he is a
middle class or maybe upper middle class
Long Island dad he's got two kids he's
got a wife he's not particularly heinous
looking he's of course not good looking
right but he's a very mediocre middle of
the road Long Island guy with a rumbled
you know collar a wrinkled polo shirt
you wouldn't think twice about him you
would see him uh picking up something at
the grocery store for his family dinner
you would not think of him at all uh in
this way and yet
he's out there
murdering
sex workers
uh and depositing their bodies in Gilgo
Beach
and it probably excited him because he
probably had a very you know boring life
and this was his way of
kind of you know
doing something exciting you know
picking up these sex workers and and
then taking them down to Gilgo Beach and
murdering them
um me and Ray talked about this on the
patreon
and literally he was discovered the next
week it's very interesting who is
listening to this show
who is listening
um
does the wife the wife hasn't given any
interviews right I mean on camera no and
I mean we don't know much about this guy
either
um
uh
it is funny the two kids will have to
eventually tell people that my wife is
my I'm sorry my father is the guy who
killed those hookers at Gilgo you know
the Gilgo Beach killer that's my dad
um
what are his kids do
they haven't visited him in jail
is that the family this is the family
let's take a look at that family
they have not visited him in jail yet
which you know by the way I don't love
this
I don't love the not visiting him in
jail I don't love the divorce
I think
that a family means something
and
you know out of sheer morbid curiosity
you're not gonna do you know if my dad
was the Gilda Beach killer I would be so
happy to talk to my father
do you know how interested I would be in
talking to my father and I love my
father but do you know how much more
interesting he would be to me if he had
killed four hookers in Google I would be
at the jail every day every day and be
like Dad how did this happen what did it
feel like are you into this do you think
I'm into this You're a murderer Dad
what's the deal what night did it happen
like I would be so interested in it and
I know that
you know
I guess it's different when you're
actually going through it but literally
I'm not kidding if my father was to
Gilgo Beach murderer
I'd be like well this is such a
fascinating and these people what are
they doing
no offense Human family but look at you
one of them has a backpack on the wrong
way
you know it it's to me it's like this
family should kind of in but listen
let's
let's be honest here why don't you
Embrace this this is your shot
this is actually your only shot
to get it to do anything on this planet
the only time anyone's gonna ever listen
or want to hear you talk is in
conjunction with this okay your dad did
a good thing here a little bit for you
he kind of did
there's there was a humdrum existence of
nothingness that lie ahead of you there
might be a book there might be a movie
there might be a mini series you might
be now
something because your father cut those
[__] up at Gilgo Beach
you might be
capital I would capital I would be
capitalizing on it immediately now you
got to get over that he did it that's
number one
your dad's a murderer
get over it see a therapist
work out
or more likely have a sandwich
whichever Long Island way you want to
handle it now once you get to the other
side of that
dad's a murderer
start thinking about striking while the
Iron's hot
because to me this is the most
interesting thing that has happened to
these people
my father was the Gilgo Beach murderer
my husband was the Gilgo Beach burner
and I think you'll find that people
won't care that much negatively I
actually think you're going to be cool
now I think people will like you now I I
I actually think this is a positive
all-around for everyone
except the victims we have of course and
this man that got caught it's not good
but this is something that's actually
you were the coolest person at every
party right now
you are the coolest you've never been
the coolest person at the party you've
never I can tell but looking at all of
you you've never been the coolest person
to put you the coolest person at every
[__] party right now you were the
coolest and most interesting member of
every friend group you've ever been a
part of right now because of nothing
you've done because of your father
utilize this this is actually to be
honest with you not the worst thing that
has happened to you this is not the
worst thing yes you have to wrestle with
the idea that your father is a violent
psychopath moving on
it's interesting though you know you can
take that and run with it and there
might be something good to get to
use it
I mean this is the time
to really examine your life and I just
think it's a very personally I feel it's
a very exciting time of renewal
for that family it's maybe
and people might not agree with this but
in my mind
it's probably the best thing that could
have happened
make that photo bigger
this
is the best thing that could have
happened to those three people
without question
without
question this is a good thing ultimately
for those three there's no way he was
such a great dad
there's no way
now you are
you've become interesting people your
life has Stakes now it matters
you get up every day and you're
examining things your heart is racing
people are staring at you they're
judging you you're taking long drives on
the Loop Parkway at 1am the music's
blasting you're in it the life that was
passing you by that everyone else seemed
to be living the interesting [__] that
everybody else went through on reality
shows or in magazines now it's happening
to you
I mean and they don't even seem grateful
but maybe somewhere down deep they are
but this is life now you have to sink
your teeth into it
I don't know I just I can't understand
people that are that don't
go at this head first
they want their privacy well that's done
and it's America and it's 2023 nobody
wants their privacy nobody
nobody wants their privacy
does it say what the kids do for a
living
does it say what they do I know one was
pretty young here hold on
I think it makes you
I think those things are actually good
in a relationship
to have to admit your father is a Gilgo
Beach killer because
it's again it's bonds you
um
so the wife is 60 she was married to Rex
for over 20 years they have two children
a daughter Victoria 26 and a special
needs son Christopher who's 33. all
right well the special needs son who's
we can't expect him
to really capitalize too much on this
and you know but Victoria 26 really
should
you know
um
and what does the wife say here Google
beaches back Rex human's wife breaks
silence because my children are cry cry
themselves to sleep
her adult children cry themselves asleep
well I well I gotta be honest with you
it's because it's because you know that
that may need to happen for a few nights
but then I think we need to see this uh
you know differently we got to look at
this to a different lens and um
I would just say that
dude I would reconnect like if my
friend's dad did this I would call him
immediately and I would be like I like I
would reconnect with that person
dude how I mean think about it is there
anything better and by the way I kind of
hope one of my friends dads does do
something like this so I could reconnect
with them we're just taking a walk and
I'm like man what's been going on he
said my dad's a [__] murderer and
immediately you're close with someone
again and you're really good friends
with them again and it's like it's
actually amazing it's actually
preferable
if someone's father's a murderer because
then you can connect with them on a deep
level here so I just actually don't feel
I don't feel bad for the no offense I
don't feel bad for the family I feel bad
for the hookers who died and I feel bad
for the guy who got caught
the guy I got caught I feel bad for and
I feel bad for the hookers but as far as
a family if you're 26 and you can't find
a way to spin this in a gold [__] you